experts in Italy have authenticated a
painting that vanished more than two
decades ago Gustav Klimt portrait of a
lady was discovered in December and
Friday evening authorities announced the
results of their investigation Seth
Doane reports from Rome it was a missing
masterpiece a decades-old mystery in the
art world and while many questions still
remain a big one was it real has now
been answered there she was against her
green background looking as if nothing
had happened yet I'd like to say with no
lack of emotion that I can announce the
painting is authentic prosecutor or
nella chica told press Friday this
priceless piece portrait of a lady
painted around 1916 by the Austrian
master Gustav Klimt had gone missing
from a gallery in the Italian city of
Piacenza nearly 23 years ago
then in December Italian police were
called to the scene after a gardener at
the same gallery had get this cleared
away ivy revealing a small door and a
hole in a wall inside was a plastic bag
with the masterpiece Klimt best-known
work may be the kiss but his love and
appreciation for women and their beauty
is seen throughout his art where he
often painted socialites in Vienna with
a seductive tenderness something rather
romantic about an art theft even though
in a very practical sense it's probably
the most foolish kind of robbery to have
colors vary Robert Simon is in New York
art historian and dealer who suggests
one problem for thieves may have been
how easily identifiable this was this is
a there's a famous painting well
documented so to sell it it's kind of an
impractical idea adding to the value of
this work and helping to authenticate it
is that Klimt painted this lady on top
of another one there is a second
portrait underneath our investigators
will hold on to that portrait for a
while longer to carry out additional
tests to see if it holds more clues
including who might have stolen it
for CBS this morning Saturday Seth Doane
row talk about a found treasure treasure
that is right
you